Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
And I'm really excited because it's election season and we've narrowed it down to the two best candidates.
I don't really like either of those candidates. Can I see some independent candidates?
Oh no they didn't get enough signatures to get on the ballot this year.
But the two main people got enough signatures to get on the ballot?
No no no they don't need signatures, the two main parties are automatically on the ballot.
Because they get the most votes every election?
Exactly.
Because they're automatically on the ballot?
Oh the debate's about to start. I can't wait these are the two best candidates available.
There's nobody else better, nobody.
Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
There is a cat stuck in a tree.
I'll call the police.
Okay uh i just saw a fender bender.
And there's a homeless lady looks like she needs to—
I'll call the police.
And a parade coming by.
Police.
School hall monitor?
You know what? I'm gonna go join that protest about excessive reliance on police.
Oh I may get to call the military on this
one.
Hello I'm a citizen. And I'm the
government.
My nephew just turned 18.
Oh that's great to celebrate he can sign
up to go to war.
Uh what?
Yeah when a guy turns 18 they have to sign up to go to a foreign country and kill people with automatic weapons.
Okay yeah. Or I thought we could celebrate by having a beer.
Oh no no no that is illegal. He's just a kid. Come on man.
You break that law and we will prosecute him as an adult.
We've prosecuted ten-year-olds as adults
before.